qu'est-ce que je suis content de
retrouver les cheveux il est 19 heures
quarante ans on est passé avec désolé
que jean lavaud bien
mons ouest il est bon si tu arrives là
une sorte tout le monde qu'est ce qui
vous arrive sur vous on est alors gérant
michel les côtes d'armor chantait
interquartiers de pétanque en travel mi
2017 et 17 août et regardez moi bien
dans les yeux je regarde quand vais je
regarde dans les yeux moi je suis là
pour dire des vérités d'accord décisive
à la pompe présenté sur l'océan dallaire
attend les maires qui te dis j'en ai
marre en tout cas le ton dans la roue
verte tourner la culture c'est-à-dire
barbie seront but est excellent terrain
et que ça et terra j'ai créé pour
l'application ou non nous lâche va dit
c'est quoi ça s'appelle un stade 3 g
trois gros c'est pour faire les à poirot
entre amis entre collègues de bureau
pour
voilà ce qu'ils sont l'ancienne école
c'est qu'ils sont l'ancienne école bomba
était tel numéro de téléphone qui les a
fait 5 millions deuxième semaine 3
millions la semaine dernière il était en
dessous des 3 millions bah oui bah oui
bon écoute des papayes avec un couteau
suisse
non mais oui non mais c'est pas possible
on peut pas couper des fruits comme ça
en prime time sur tf1 nous a fait plus
de mal aux trois semaines que ben may
mondiale en 20 ans de carrière
et dieu sait que bernard montiel nous a
fait mal ça il va soulever il faut que
ça cesse mais bordel de merde qu'est ce
que je fais
il faut le stopper
hitano je vous donne l'ordre de le
stopper
ap
[Musique]
je salue bien d'ailleurs président vous
parce que vous avez eu la copine sarah
mieux d'écouter ce sabbat ça va ça va
j'ai eu quelques jours compliqués comme
vous le savez j'ai gtl isolement
d'ailleurs j'en ai profité pour regarder
des prime de tf1 et j'ai vite relativisé
sur mon cas en me disant que finalement
il ya pire que j'ai à présent tueur plus
depuis le début d'année j'ai pris des
nouvelles résolutions attention
présiderait beaucoup beaucoup de peine
les chéris des gros gros problème de son
ce soir je suis vraiment désolé
franchement les cherry on va essayer
d'arranger ça bien sûr c'est les
techniciens sont dessus est ce qu'on
peut avoir quelqu'un de la régie souple
et mercy est ce que vous pouvez faire un
peu plus vite merci à ces lionel sera
non plus s'il vient c'est le dgs est le
patron il a pas de micro donc sans micro
déjà qu on nous entend pas il essaye un
troisième secours on essaye la 5 minute
un troisième c'est court si les
problèmes seront alors moi ce que je
vois c'est qu'on mette la pub tout de
suite voile et après on va aller tout
droit dont il y aura plus de pub jusqu'à
la fin de l'émission on essaye de régler
ce problème pendant une petite page de
pub si c'est bon on continuera à
l'antenne si c'est pas bon les chéris
malheureusement on sera obligé de rendre
l'antenne ce soir en direct à tout de
suite c'est bon bravo
[Applaudissements]
stéphane bern c'est la classe
rien à dire c'est la classe non mais
franchement mon stéphane comment ça va
mon chéri d'amour mais merci merci
d'abord merci cyril pour l'honnêteté
avec laquelle tu tues tu as la région
fait amende honorable en quelque sorte
mais au fond ils font la leçon à tirer
c'est qu'il faut il faut pas se moquer
des émissions avant de les avoir
regardés
c'est mon problème ça
si à tous d'avoir été aussi nombreux à
regarder les cholet reçoit et les séries
ce matin en voyant les audiences je me
suis dit hé mec est ce qu'on tient pas
un truc avec une émission samson est ce
que l'émission marcherait pas bien sans
que nous ne faisons pas ça fait des
années qu'on essaie de nous faire taire
et parce que c'est pas la bonne solution
saas est touchée doigt sur tf1 par mois
je sais pas on attend les 150000 euros
quoi par 150 me voir et moi moi c'est à
moi oui j'avoue j'avais dit aux gars que
j'avais la une est à vous non j'avais
plein de spécial et spéciale sans arrêt
je me demande je vais le voter
les anglais ne sont pas plus
irresponsable et la l'épidémie flambe
chez eux à cause du nouveau variant
soixante mille nouveaux cas tous les
jours
maâk ya une catastrophe dans les
hôpitaux le système de santé est dépassé
donc il ya un confinement très strictes
qui est mis en place avec la fermeture
des écoles chose que nous n'avons pas
installer et peut-être qu'il ya des
choses qui vont expliquer ça est une
forme de lassitude
on commence à en avoir marre du
coronavirus donc peut-être qu'on se
relâche un peu dans les gestes barrière
il ya le variante du virus
et puis l hiver avec notamment les fêtes
de fin d'année on a pu un peu profité
est-ce qu'on va le payer très cher donc
à mon sens le confinement je vais pas
faire madame soleil mais pourrait
peut-être arriver si l'épidémie flanc
nombre sur un plateau assez haut
c'est à dire que ça peut flamber dans un
sens ou au contraire se calme et on ose
à l'auto entre quinze et vingt mille cas
par jour une date ou un protocole
pourquoi le protocole sanitaire c'est
pas bon pour nous il ne fonctionne pas
dans la restauration parce qu'une étude
américaine indique pour les fast food
c'était pas mon et on pourquoi on sait
pas faire des études en france c'est par
faire des vaccins en france on peut
demander à un psy cher de faire des
vaccins vous avez vous vous êtes mariés
non je suis honoré d'être célibataire
voyez le métier à vous êtes en train de
vous dire vous allez perdre votre ville
peut être dans un mois mais on va tout
perdre mais pas moi on y 240000
restaurateurs vous les aimez vos
restaurants on est bien sûr bien sûr est
d'accord vous avez tous des potes qui
travaille dans la restauration à vous
connaissez les grands chefs et compagnie
donc à un moment donné vous savez la
peine qu'ils ont
tout est parti d'une parodie qu'on a
diffusé lundi dans tpm paix sur arthur
avec l'un de mes films préférés
si ce n'est mon film préféré le
professionnel avec jean paul belmondo
vous le savez qui est un ami que j'aime
j'embrasse d'ailleurs jeff et jean-paul
qui doivent me regarder actuellement en
direct moi moi je trouve que la
proportion est beaucoup plus important
en ce moment et c'est vrai que là c'est
une parodie est vraiment là en plus on
était vraiment hyper sympa avec les
ministres yves dette on peut pas dire
les shérifs district z marche je vais on
va pas vrai c'est comme lego masters je
le dis lego resther c'est notre boîte de
production on l'a dit vous n'avez vu de
la juger j'étais pas mal tu le fais
d'hervé ou david hicks avait dégringolé
en audience même moi je me suis dit bon
quand même fort mais on est obligé de
dire les choses oui moi je pense que tf1
n'a pas compris une chose c'est que tpm
paix est une émission médias c'est dans
la démission de critiquer et navo bien
auprès de passau si ceux ci nous avait
dit fin la critique est en bien ou en
mal les émissions de m6 de france 2 de
france 3-2 ses huit vous face à cette
situation
vous avez décidé d'entamer une grève de
la faim oui pour garder votre apprenti
vous ne mangez plus depuis dimanche à
minuit oui ça va quand dans samedi
minuit samedi minutes comment vous
sentez super bien qu avec vous non
vraiment vous sentez indien non mes
premiers deuxième jour il est à fond
parce qu'ils ont excité puis on puisse
grâce aux réseaux sociaux enfin que j'ai
pas si vous avez vu les liens sur la
justice et police a été marqué mais on a
cent quarante ans parce qu'ici on chez
moi où on à 404 signature et vous
considère est là et c'est un grand
taiseux ylang autant un grand sourire
qu'ils étaient eux mêmes donc ils super
discret que jamais on l'entend fourni
est-ce qu'il parle français
oui comment encore mieux que moi c'est
assez important pour l'intégration mais
il n'y a pas eu d'intégration il était
bien intégrée des qualités de l'arrivée
alors aujourd'hui on va attendre la
session vous allez faire la grève de la
faim jusqu'au 26 janvier
alors je vais essayer vous avez essayé
mais ça serait plutôt des relations
parce que c'est vrai que j'avais déjà
fait petit problème de santé mais vous
avez vous avez pas peur pour votre santé
vous faites suivre willimon infirmière
qui vient tous les trois jours
mais comment si si je ne fais pas qui
c'est qui le fait qu'andy un petit merci
d'être là dans dix trésorerie vous
rencontrez bien sûr j'ai suivi la
cérémonie
sylvie ma chérie comment ça va mais ça
va mon année soit bonne année massy
ligne alors je lui ai eus au téléphone
sylvie jeudi bonne année et ben voilà
elle était dans le jury
1 on s'envoyait des petits sms on peut
le dire voilà mon sort et des pièces et
mais cela pendant la cérémonie ou moment
elle a pris la parole et à elodie
gossuin à côté de moi et je dis à ce
pour moi c'est elle miss france et
amandine je vous dis et je pense que
sylvie est d'accord avec nous je pense
que vous avez fait la différence pour
vous avez pris la parole à la fin c'est
vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui m'ont
dit à attention amandine elle a un truc
en plus
est ce que vous êtes dit c'est amandine
qui va gagner alors moi je ne vois
jamais la miss france mais vraiment pas
très doué pour pour savoir qui va être
élu et franchement cette année on avait
quand même une super promo et ce pour
les cinq finalistes pense qu'on avait
cinq miss france
est-ce que vous avez été triste tout ce
qui s'est passé avec geneviève de
fontenay bonsaï faire nos matches lors
de la soirée parce que ça nous rend
tristes au squelette non parce que
geneviève je la connais on sait et
nathalie le c'est geneviève elle
embrasse le lundi elle gifle mardi voilà
ça fait partie de son personnage pense
que je vais vous en remercier pour la
ferme super communiqué le dimanche que
j'ai appelé le miracle de noël et je
tiens à remercier parce que
ladite l'émission était très belle que
on avait une façon moi le seul regret
c'est qu'elles soient pas son plateau
parce que l on l'a vu avec toutes les
miss france on voulait vraiment lui
rendre hommage
nice france est-elle ça sera toujours
geneviève quoi pendant 10 et alors elle
aurait eu sa place le 19 décembre c'est
dommage que sa venue bonsoir merci
d'être là ça va sanaa - johan pas friand
c'est pas la folie non il a 36 ans 36
ans yohann ça démarre en septembre
labour chanter les premiers symptômes
ouais perte de goût l'odorat des maux de
tête violents
alors là je pose la question je me dis
mais moi j'ai fait un test
j'avais tous les symptômes pourquoi il
était négatif
et là j'apprends que si le virus est
passé dans les bronches il est il est
plus détectable et ils me disent voilà
c'est la situation est vraiment critique
et on va être obligé de vous un tube et
parce que il vous faut un maximum
d'oxygène dans les poumons et pour la
première fois de ma vie
j'entends ce ce médecin qui est devant
moi et qui me dit monsieur banny la
situation est grave il faut que vous en
ayez conscience
le pronostic vital est plus qu'engagé et
je vais être franc avec vous parce que
je dois pas vous je dois pas vous le
cacher mais vous risquez de mourir
[Musique]